this is a message from the government
[Music]
hello and welcome to that was the work
that was a summary of all the brilliant
progressive things
that have happened this year i'm
constantly kissing and you may remember
me from my stint
hosting a kids tv show on al jazeera and
i'm francis foster
a man who looks like a cross between
louis theroux and a beaver
this year has been such a disaster it
makes 2016
look like a vegan sister who uses her
copy of white fragility as a comfort toy
2020 was the first time the scariest
halloween outfit was not wearing a mask
i turned up at a halloween party and
when they asked me what i came as
i said man with persistent cough but
thanks to the ingenuity of scientists
we finally have something that allows
you to avoid infection
even when you're congregating with
thousands of other people in a mostly
peaceful protest
i give you the fisa triple c protection
blm t-shirt
100 immunity against covet criticism
and criminal prosecution we've been
following the science and thankfully we
now know more about the virus
kobit 19 only affects people in cafes
restaurants bars and anti-lockdown
marches
if you've had dinner out recently you've
killed granny
which is disgusting unless she voted
brexit
in which case she is racist stump and
you are legally required to push her in
front of a combine harvester
2020 has been a great year for promoting
black voices
unless of course they contradict the
mainstream liberal narrative in which
case
they ain't black yes any black person
who thinks of themselves should be
treated as if
you are a wealthy slave owner from 19th
century alabama
and you've heard there's just been an
escape from the plantation
same if you're a woman critical of
transitioning kids
shut your mouth and don't worry your
pretty little head about it unless
you're a lesbian
because it can be a bit scary lesbians
aren't scary they are if you wake up and
see one in the mirror
every morning one evil bigger who voiced
her opinion on the trans issue this year
is jk rowling formerly beloved by the
work
she now apparently hates all trans
people and was widely reported to have
misgendered a dragon
harry potter actor daniel radcliffe was
horrified and denounced jk rowling in
public
who would have thought daniel wouldn't
know what a real man is but there have
been winners in 2020
it's been a great year for nonces and if
you're american
and don't know what a nonsense it's one
of them what a philanthropist with a
hobby and a really long notebook
exactly every celebrity pervert can now
breathe
a sight of relief now that their best
mate has decided to do the decent thing
and kill himself
he resisted ending it with all his might
but they killed himself
anyway another person now desperately
trying to avoid suicide
is nonce whisperer jillaine maxwell a
woman so hated she makes her dad robert
maxwell who stole half a billion pounds
from a pension fund
looked like an okay guy but the real
winner of 2020
is your weed smoking grade a conspiracy
theorist
well done gary it turns out that
spending hours
wanking yourself dry to alex jones
videos wasn't
a complete waste of time it was research
for the [ __ ] of insanity that is
2020.
it has been a tough year for princess
harry and prince megan
all they wanted was a bit of privacy and
netflix disney and spotify just won't
leave them alone there really is nothing
more 2020 than a prince and hollywood
actress lecturing ordinary people about
privilege
in fairness to harry if i was dating
megan and she asked me to identify as an
anti-semitic martian i'd happily invade
earth destroy
all the jews and lead the labour party
to victory in 2024.
speaking as a jew i'd marry her as well
she is a millionaire
but anyway salvation is on the horizon
the vaccine
no rishi sunak is handing out free cash
do you want to see a clip of dishy in
action okay
oh my god
but let's talk about the vaccine which
one pfizer
oxford the australian one no sputnik
five
can't wait to take it never liked making
eye contact anyway i'm gonna get me a
triple dose
convince tom cruise i'm his older
brother and head for the nearest casino
i'm gonna make so much dirty money
they're gonna call me hunter biden
i don't think that's how it works that's
what an anti-vaxxer would say but anyway
let's talk about the u.s election
two of the worst candidates in history
went head to head and america held its
breath
why because of coving no you idiot they
were worried one of the candidates might
actually win to be fair joe biden looked
like captain america
after he had a massive stroke and donald
trump a man
so divisive he could start a war at a
silent yoga retreat
it doesn't really matter because the
moment carmela is alone with joe biden
she's going to cough right into his
mouth and he's going to die
a second time should we make fun of
carmilla harris no
that would be racist really i know it's
confusing
being racist used to mean being
prejudiced against people because of the
color of the skin
but we're better than that now to
educate the nation
we're gonna play wheel of racism
where's the wheel shut up we're on a
budget right
francis in a minute or less name as many
racist things
as you can go okay i know the answer to
this trump boris johnson
uh society the countryside republicans
punctuality people who say the word
instead of people of color
bane the word black black conservative
black republicans people who criticize
white people people who criticize
blm people who are talking but should be
listening people are listening but
should be talking
people who take the who don't take the
knee people who take the knee but don't
admit their own inherent bias people who
attend
antibiotics training people who don't
attend antibiotics training
and penguins are you black are you white
[ __ ] off the same goes for killer whales
congratulations i've got one more answer
i've got one more answer
being racist to white people
you have failed your unconscious bias
test you are now officially racist and
the police will be along shortly
to check your thinking the british
government have banned
meeting friends indoors meeting friends
outdoors walking the dog
protesting and even having sex without
social distancing
they've also banned dancing in public
which is great news for white men
everywhere finally a tory policy i can
get behind
but let's not forget the labour party
led by kierstama
a man who permanently looks like he's
doing a missing cat appeal they have
spent so much time sitting on the fence
they've officially renamed the party to
abstention rebellion the conservative
party have
bankrupted this country mishandled the
coronavirus
alienated their core voters pissed off
their new voters
and antagonized the whole of the north
of england
and they're still more popular than the
labour party that's like applying to the
head of a women's charity and losing out
to jessica janet
wax your balls ladies but in all
seriousness we wish
all our viewers patrons subscribers a
very very merry christmas
let's hope it's a white one made the
police are here we're not socially
distant